[Musique]
c'est la fin idéale
quant à son journal pour les nouvelles
j'espère qu'elles seront chauds société
frei afghan portable fafn à eibar
zimbawe son coup si les petits
commérages l'autre petit écho de la
forêt c'est très serré il y à toutes les
informations à chaque nouvelle édition
on n'a jamais de déception ça vous le
découvrirez dans le cul des cours de
l'offre
[Musique]
[Rires]
excusez moi certaines femmes mais je
sais que j'ai d'avoir qui est arrivé à
fifi la fourmi alors assurément que
cette four et j'aime le ménage et de
nettoyage à il aurait quoi j'ai
notamment la vivre et voyager
je veux que ma maison soit la plus
propre de la forêt il y va de la
réputation des fourmis mais quel travail
je lis la syrie débarqués en caustique
et mes meubles laver les carreaux les
cils et des peintures comme reste-t-il à
faire
j'oubliais il faut que je suis comme
étape et certains supports dont
mademoiselle de la cigogne avait décidé
de son côté de faire sa culture physique
quotidienne extension des ailes
on respire extension de la patte droite
on reste une extension de la patte
gauche
on respire maintenant est celle de la
cigogne passait devant la maison de fifi
juste au moment où celle-ci se coincer
tapis par la fenêtre
il aimait voyager leur passage et là des
crotales et l'aide à gaza
et là de quoi j'aime le meddat h
vous avez attrapé un but malmazet de
l'acide a dû tout fifi c'est votre
poussière de quelques poussières parlez
vous faisiez vous dire que mes tapis
sont remplies de poussière évidemment
plus que voulait secouer de secours mais
tapie c'est justement pour les empêcher
avant de la poussière parce que moi je
déteste la poussière et puis j'adore
battre l'état puisse être s'amusant cela
me fait cet exercice c'est excellent et
aimerait bien continuer eu la cigogne la
dire à tous ses amis
ce qu'elle venait d'apprendre décidément
notre fille fille a de drôles de manille
et qu'elle manie elle prétend qu'elle
adore battre des tapis
ça il trouve que c'est une leçon et que
c'est excellent pour s'affronter au elle
nous raconte des histoires mois au world
hildebrand quelle bonne idée serbo
hisser ce qui fit filles aimaient tant
battre tapis mois allés lui porter tapis
à moi c'est ce que je vais faire aussi
mais aussi et au moins de temps qu'il
n'en faut pour le dire
un amoncellement de tapis s'entassent à
devant la porte de fifi la fourmi et
mesdemoiselles de la cigogne tir à la
sonnette et la mademoiselle vous avez
fini entre un train ter physique mais
vous vous avez fini votre ménage
on est malheureusement pourquoi
malheureusement parce que je m'ennuie
que je n'ai rien à faire
maël vous pourriez secoué bon tapis je
les ai déjà sur près de 10 fois et si
vous en aviez d'eau s'il y en avait
d'autres jolystes critiquaient une du
quotidien vous savez que je suis une
femme une femme fait et si vous avez un
voeu à formuler
je voulais exempt serait tout de suite
tout de suite su que je ne peux rien
souhaiter tout ce qu'il me faut vous
venez de me dire que vous n'aviez plus
de ta pièce coup il est vrai et si j'en
voulais vous voilà porteriez à l'instant
mais ne manquera pas réussi qu'est ce
que je risque est bien belle fait je
voudrais je le draveur tous les tapis de
la forêt et ce cui à bach à l'abri
abracadabra ces tapis
les voilà mais c'est une horreur
pourquoi vous m'aviez dit que vous
adoriez secoué les tapis
oui mais quand vous trouviez ça amusant
est que c'était excellent pour votre
santé
alors de quoi vous plaignez vous rien
qu'à tiens à remercier mois plus tôt
merci bon courage
ou plutôt amusez vous bien et c'est
pauvre fille fille du secoué tous les
tapis de la forêt pendant des journées
entières en disant qu'il adorait ça il
arrive à tout le monde de raconter des
histoires
n'est ce pas chercher les fans ne peut
qu à bientôt
je compte sur vous pour la prochaine
édition du petit etc ou de la forêt
outils